bonjour franck bonjour bienvenue dans un
aparté merci beaucoup c'est absolument
ravis de vous accueillir je suis ravi
d'être là et on va s'y mettre chez
quelqu'un que je connais pas mais qui a
quand même les mêmes goûts que moi cette
femme avant comme maintien thiam
sensations ça veut dire que vous validez
la déco
alors d'abord je vais vous dire je suis
très content d'être là parce que je suis
un grand fan de la version originale
la déco bravo voilà vous pouvez l'idée
do
we vous repérer des petites choses qui
vous parle
c'est chouette
je vous laisse faire connaissance avec
les lieux et repérer peut-être est
effectivement qu'est ce que vous voyez
là face à vous et qui vous est a priori
connu à baky et kim qui est ma vue de
tous les jours la place de la bastille
voulez je vous raconte pourquoi basté je
vais bien parce que moi je viens melun
la banlieue sud de paris et
j'ai tellement souvent pris le rer d qui
m'emmène à gare de lyon pour que j'aï
manger une crêpe à bastille et je me
disais si un jour j'ai un peu d'argent
j'adorerais avoir un appartement ici ça
doit être super et puis ce moment est
arrivé donc j'invite investi et j'adore
ça dans mon quartier et si je vais plus
loin vous disiez aussi voilà manger
effectivement des crêpes côté de la rue
de la roquette et après ken une meuf
je
me suis
alors les crêpes les creps et le clin
d'oeil évident évidemment les crêpes
c'est le syndic je vais écouter bien sûr
alors vous avez crêpes au beurre salé
trop sucré voilà l'exemple des fois
quand on fait des émissions de télé et
quoi
on nous met là la bouffe à l'est pas
c'est à dire qu'ils allaient tenir
longtemps mais là les tiennent oui c'est
servir
enfin le deuxième à bas les ij faites
vous plaisir elles sont pour vous
regardez une pour pour la presse
j'ai envie de vous parler de je vous dis
voilà vous validez la déco de
l'appartement c'était un petit clin
d'oeil c'était un petit clin d'oeil
évidemment à la saison 2 votre série
déjà culte sur le rap on peut pas ne pas
en parler parce que ça arrive ex est
d'ores et déjà annoncé comme tonitruant
come pénètrera oui avec il ya eu les
kaïra shopping s'essaye à 15 ans il ya
eu le film ensuite hélas la saison 2 de
valider qui arrive vous êtes comment
valider de 7,2 démarrage très attendu
ouais bah en fait c'est laisser ses
on pourrait dire que c'est difficile de
revenir après un succès comme celui là
parce que le risque de décevoir
forcément est grand mais en même temps
ce succès énorme à
nous a donné avec les auteurs une force
une motivation pour s'enfermer écrire
une saison 2 c'est quand même enfin
c'est quand même un truc positif par un
truc négatif d'être autant attendu et
d'avoir fait une série qui a rencontré
un public aussi large donc voilà ça nous
a donné beaucoup de force et
puis dans cette saison 2 on a appris
plein de risques pour vous raconter
plein d'autres choses pour surprendre
pour procurer des émotions parce que
c'est ça qui est incroyable avec la
série c'est quand même vous procure des
émotions quoi oui alors on va se
raconter un peu maintenant que vous êtes
bien calé dans le fauteuil on va
rappeler quelques chiffres si vous le
voulez bien 42 ans acteur scénariste
real producteurs vous êtes surtout